hello everyone
I'm AJ alanuma producer of The Legend of
Zelda series
first I have some news
development on the Legend of Zelda tears
of the kingdom is now complete
thank you very much for waiting
many of you are looking forward to this
game and we've released a few trailers
so far
although it'll just be a brief Glimpse
I'm going to actually play the game for
you all today and show you what it's
like
okay let's begin
here we are in the land of Hyrule
like The Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild there is a vast world to explore of
course it's not just the same world as
is it's changed in many ways if we talk
about all of the changes today we'll run
out of time so we hope you'll seek them
out for yourself when the game launches
in this game the vast world of Hyrule
reaches High into the sky you'll notice
some land masses floating up there we
call them Sky Islands
you're probably wondering something how
do you get to the sky islands when
they're so high up there
if we take a look oh something's falling
from the sky
do you see it I wonder what that is
let's head over to it
we are almost at the spot where the
object fell
here it is
okay let's use one of Link's new
abilities
if you do this on the rock that just
fell
look it started Rising
this power is known as recall which
rewinds an object's movement
since I just used recall on the Fallen
Rock I can now rise into the sky we're a
lot closer to the sky islands let's use
the paraglider to reach one of them
there are a few other Sky Islands
floating here too
I made it
there are lots of ways to reach the sky
islands so we hope you'll try a few
different methods
okay now we're on a slightly bigger Sky
Island
just like on the surface there are
several man-made structures
some trees are also growing here
you won't see many of those yellow trees
on the surface though
let's walk around for a bit
there's a branch on the ground when you
find something like this you should pick
it up it might come in handy later
let's continue
oh something's there this is a brand new
enemy called a construct we'll fight it
using the branch we just picked up
ah the branch broke not good not good
quick get another branch and
we defeated it
moving on
we've now explored more of this Sky
Island
as expected fighting with just a branch
won't get us very far come also this
branch is almost broken so here's
another one of Link's new abilities if
we use this branch and the rock over
here and do this
look we can stick them together we
created a makeshift Hammer this is
called fuse you can stick objects
together to create new weapons with
various effects
let's take on another construct with
this fused weapon
we're dealing with two of them at once
[Music]
oh we beat one
the weapons attack has definitely
improved
the other Branch broke but this weapon
has much better durability
you can do all sorts of things by
experimenting with the fusibility
you confuse two weapons for example if
we take this long stick and fuse it with
a pitchfork
we can create a weapon with a much
longer attack range
with this we don't have to get too close
to enemies and we can safely attack from
a distance
you can also fuse Arrows with materials
in your inventory
for instance try fusing this Leaf to an
arrow
fuse an ice Elemental material to an
arrow and
you can freeze far away enemies
very useful
in addition
let's see
ah there's a bird flying around if
you're out hunting you might feel that
aiming with an arrow is too difficult
apparently my eyes can't track fast
moving objects as of late so my shots
rarely land
so at times like these
here's an eyeball you can get by
defeating monsters
fuse it to an arrow and
look it homed in on the target
let's try this on another bird
I'll just fire in that General Direction
that's very simple
depending on what you stick together the
fusibility could also be beneficial for
hunting
I fused a mushroom to my shield
now you're probably wondering if this
has any use well this mushroom is
actually a puff shroom
let's fight an enemy with this
I blocked with the shield
okay there's smoke now the enemies lost
sight of links so attack
even if you struggle with combat you can
take down enemies using similar methods
in the previous game you'd usually get
powerful weapons by defeating strong
enemies but in this game fusing even the
weakest weapon with something else could
turn it into a useful weapon there are
even more gameplay options for sticking
things together let me demonstrate
some of the sky islands even have Rivers
we'll want to cross this one but
swimming across it well the river's too
wide for that we need a boat
of course there isn't anything that
resembles a boat around here
so we'll lift up this log and attach it
to a second log
okay let's do one more we'll bring this
over here and attach a third log
it's a makeshift raft
this is another new ability called Ultra
hand
even though the logs are currently
attached they can be detached let's
modify the shape of the raft
you can always attach things or detach
them like this
now if we put this on the water it's
made of wood so the buoyancy will keep
it afloat
we've made a simplified version of a
boat
however it won't move in its current
state so we'll need something to propel
it forward
there's something here let's try hitting
it
oh a wind it's blowing wind
looks like we found a fan why don't we
try attaching it
we'll attach another one this should
make the boat well balanced
foreign
okay they're attached
all right let's try moving the boat
[Music]
hey it's moving
it's sailing pretty fast with the Wind
from the fans
since we added two fans we should be
able to cross the river in no time
all right we reached the other side
in the most recent trailer we showed
scenes of Link riding a large car and a
flying machine
those Vehicles actually aren't in the
game from the start instead you'll be
able to freely craft them on your own
there are all sorts of objects you'll
come across in this game and depending
on how you use your imagination you can
do a lot with them so try crafting
different things and explore this world
at your leisure
there are even more new abilities
take this building over here okay watch
this
okay
look I passed right through the ceiling
this new ability is called Ascend if
you're in a place with a ceiling you can
go through
to the floor above you
there are some restrictions but what's
great about this ability is that as long
as there's a ceiling you can use it
anywhere
for example this place has a cave with a
hill right above it
if we use the Ability here
come on
keep going
okay we emerged at the top of the hill
in the previous game you had to use
stamina to climb a mountain but in this
game if there's a mountain with a cave
like this one you can now get to the top
without having to climb all the way up
here's another example imagine you're
stuck in a cage if it's got a ceiling
you know what to do right exactly
oh there's another construct
it seems to be holding a strange weapon
some enemies are equipped with fused
weapons so battles will play out a bit
differently from the previous game
ah it blew me away with wind
looks like it's got some sort of fan
ah I got pushed off
oh well let's just return to the surface
you can quickly descend from the sky to
the surface like this it feels so good
in the sky you'll be able to look out
across the land
you can also search for destinations
that pique your interest
once you've chosen your destination you
can speed things up like this
let's dive into this River
and we're back on the surface
there are still so many things I'd like
to show you but let's leave it at that
for now
what did you think
some of Link's new abilities were
updated from the previous game
I'm sure some of you watching me play
were thinking wait if you could do that
then maybe you could do this too
in this game you can do a lot of things
just by thinking about what's even
possible
there's still a lot of new gameplay
Mysteries and encounters we couldn't
show today but they're all jam-packed
into this unfamiliar Hyrule and we hope
you'll use your imagination to explore
it
that's all for today thank you for
watching
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign